and I just want to dip let me let me see
that man I just want
to show you guys why I got kicked out of
the game right here this is in the first
H uh this is in the third third quarter
with 128 left to go in in the third and
right here you can wa you can watch go
back and watch he uh Fox barely puts his
hand on uh on Dame's hip okay incidental
contact he didn't push him or anything
he barely puts his hand on there and
they give them three free throws now at
half we were down I think 19 to five in
the free throws 19 to5 and I know that
happens sometimes but that's very
frustrating when at the end of the half
at the end of the half from what I've
get get get get told all the time Malik
drives uh um Lopez comes over and goes
vertical with a forearm down here now
from what the NBA tells me the rule is
if you go vertical you got to have two
hands up cuz domma has his hand down
here a lot and they call him for it
every time and they always tell us well
you got a forearm here and they said
that that they said that tonight they
said forarm can be here as long as it's
not extended so I don't know what the
rules are in this situation I need a
clarification because again two hands up
is what the rule is on verticality but
they were here and they said Lopez could
do this that's a five-point swing they
take away the two free throws and then
Milwaukee goes down and hits a three and
and to in the half at 19 to5 that's
tough to deal with especially when
you're getting told different
interpretations on a rule okay so now I
go back they call this foul they call
this foul again on FOX NOW again that's
he didn't push him they they they said
it's in supposed to be incidental
contact they give him three free throws
now watch this right right here Fox
comes off a pick and roll the kid uh uh
uh campaign hooks him hooks his arm look
at Fox's look at Fox's arm when he spins
off of this hooks his arm he almost
Falls no incidental contact he hooks his
arm and almost Falls and and and there's
no foul and and and so to me as as a
coach I I I'm okay with look again boom
he almost Falls and that that's that's
at the fourth quarter at the 932 Mark
I'm okay as a coach cuz because the
referees are human and they're going to
make mistakes but you just hope a
there's some sort of consistency B
there's some sort of communication
between the refs and and the rest
tonight they were great they
communicated with me all night but in
terms of the consistency you guys saw it
right here Dame coming off the pick and
roll and Foxy getting hooked and almost
falling coming off the pick and roll and
then on top of that if you get
communication and you get some form of a
consistency in the game
okay then you can live with some things
you can live with that but but but the
consistency that I see tonight wasn't
wasn't my opinion there and then I I I I
I don't understand the rule if if if the
rule is you got to go vertical and both
hands up how can you give how can you
take away two free throws when the guy
got his forearm down here now if the if
if they're going to change the rule on
me and say okay the forearm can be down
here and the other one can be up there
all right then now I know it going
forward but that's not the rule is cuz
we get called on domas all the time and
they tell us he's got to have both hands
up if you want to go vertical that's why
I got kicked
out